that the game was over couple of dude
stuff got stolen during the game during
the game they stole the
chain insane bro it's all yours during
the game that's why I'm wear jewelry bro
I try to say that I can't wear jewelry
I'm not flashy I you think I got
anything that you would like but I still
messed up to the team bro to my
teammates cuz like hard workking money
on that stuff one of the camera guys got
their money stolen that's kind of messed
up bro they work for this stuff and
before to get stolen at a football game
after we thinking our stuff is safe I'm
not bringing no bags no more to the
weight games like you w to see me with
no bags on the weight game I probably
have a book bag and that's it like all
extra stuff no sir I mess with getting
my stuff stolen cuz I would have still
been in Cali right now trying to get my
stuff
back